RETO MEIER: Hello.
My name is Reto Meier, and
welcome to This Week in
Android Development on Monday,
August 26, 2013.
Last week, Daniel showed us
how to drag and rearrange
ListView items, and you learned
how easy it is to make
your apps work well on large
screen displays.
I used strained metaphors to
introduce a series of DevBytes
on making your app transfers
more efficient by
understanding the cell radio.
The Android Design in Action
team were at it again with
their highlight of beautiful
design for summer 2013, and a
round up of the best seasonal
[INAUDIBLE].
Our games team knows how to have
a good time, and did so
on Game On, introducing
the joy and wonder
of OpenGL ES 3.0.
This week, I'm going to be
here, toasting these.
We've used some magical
boxes to record this
update ahead of time.
Just in case something dramatic
happened over the
weekend, let me be the first
to welcome our new insect,
alien, or cyborg overlords.
Those same magic boxes made it
possible for us to film the
next episode of Efficient Data
Transfers early, and play back
some tips for analyzing
your transfer profile.
So even if the robot apocalypse
happens, this
DevByte byte will be available
to watch from the shelter of
your bunker.
Daniel is also back with another
DevByte, this time
looking at how to work with
sliding fragments.
In new releases, "Real Racing 3"
has been updated to include
full Google+ integration.
That's all for This Week
In Android Development.
Be sure to check out this week's
DevBytes, and remember
that there will be no
sleep till Brooklyn.